[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good evening your welcome to your vision
debate there is just over a week to go
before you up goes to support in the
European Parliament elections so tonight
we put the big questions of people who
want to lead so you're young Commission
for the next five years we are live from
the European Parliament in Brussels
where six candidates for the position of
President of the European Commission
will make their pitch for Europe's top
top real life across Europe on embers of
Eurovision but we are also being watched
around the world online you're all very
welcome
so we are your hosts I am a media can be
a news anchor from French TV I'm Markus
price EU correspondent with aad German
TV and I am honest Tina heckler I work
as a correspondent for the Finnish
television in Paris and I will be
guiding you through the debate on social
media but it's not about us it's about
the candidates for Europe's top job so
please welcome
Nico QA Spanish born Belgian trade
unionists a lead candidate for the
European left
[Applause]
from Germany scheduler for the European
Green Party it's her second Eurovision
debates from the Czech Republic the
answer ideal member of the European
Parliament for alliance of conservatives
and we from it in Europe acting EU
Competition Commissioner market
divestiture for the alliance of liberals
and Democrats for Europe from Germany
monthly Lib chairman of the European
People's Party in the European
Parliament and Spitz in Canada and
finally from the Netherlands France
Timmerman's first vice-president of the
European Commission the candidate of the
party of European socialists
[Music]
this debate is nothing without you all
over Europe and that's where Anna steena
comes in yes I will be your social media
host this evening so you are a crucial
part of this debate throughout the
program I will be monitoring the
millions of Europeans who are following
us online asking questions reacting and
engaging with us in the digital world so
tell us what matters to you by using the
hashtag tell Europe and make your voice
heard of course every debate has rules
handy one is no difference so these
debates will last 90 minutes each
candidate will have one minute to answer
each question and during the debates
they will have each two opportunities to
challenge other candidates and we really
encourage all of you to make use of this
rebuttal card because then we have
really a lively debate here on stage
each participant will also have the
opportunity to make opening and closing
statements speaking order was decided in
a draw and let's begin neko Korea
the floor is yours most well good
evening my name is nicko Kui
I am a candidate for the European Left
Party
I was born in Asturias in the north of
Spain when my father was a minor but he
was forced to leave Spain because he was
opposed to the Franco regime the
dictatorship we were welcomed in Belgium
by people who showed a lot of solidarity
towards us
we were able to build a home work study
and it's this solidarity that really
gave me the desire to work with Europe
it's as Europe of solidarity that I've
always fought for it as a trade union
representative and that is the Europe
that I want to continue to defend but
unfortunately this is also the Europe of
tax evasion the Europe of the banks the
Europe that has failed to show
solidarity so I would like to create a
Europe of solidarity hello everyone this
debate and these elections are important
because people from all over Europe are
looking at us and they're asking for
solutions they know many things are
going wrong from the climate crisis to
austerity to the backlash against
democracy and civil liberties Europe is
struggling to fulfill the promises that
has been built on and tonight I want to
make the case for a different Europe one
that protects our common planet the only
one that we have as social Europe where
everyone finds decent housing and has a
decent wage we as greens take the battle
for European Union where the big
companies pay their fair share where
women are truly treated equal where
minorities are respected human rights
are protected I know it is possible to
build this different Europe if we build
together and if we build it with courage
thank you very much Scott Keller and
next in line is yawns our radio good
evening everyone I believe that we
cannot meet all those new challenges of
21st century with old and outdated
scheme of every closer Union which has
been designed 50 years ago for a
different age therefore I would propose
rather you which is scaled back which is
flexible which is decentralized I would
like to have European Commission which
respects all its members regardless
whether they are big or small or whether
they are from the West or from the East
I would like to have European Commission
which respects national governments and
which cooperates with them which doesn't
fight them we
doesn't patronize them which doesn't
lecture them simply speaking I would
like to have European Union which is
doing less but better and which is able
to find new equilibrium between national
and European level and this is the
European Union and this is the change I
am ready and able to deliver thank you
yes their ideal language first I go it's
a tone I am a guy to be stea I'm from
Denmark my husband and I have three
daughters I was a minister a political
leader today I work for you as
commissioner of competition I make sure
that businesses play by the rule book
so you as a consumer have choice quality
and fair prices for me the most
important thing is that you are
empowered to live the life you want to
live in your community that you feel
counted in you have a fair chance of
making it Europe is the best place to
live today especially if you're a woman
we have achieved so much that doesn't
make everything good we have work to do
to fight climate change to deal with
technology to create societies built on
the rule of law where you can provide
for yourself to make that everyday life
that's why I'm here thank you very much
Margaret arrests occur and we take it to
monthly favor please I want to thank you
I had the opportunity in the last weeks
and months to ring my electoral campaign
to travel a lot around European Union
and to meet a lot of Europeans the
experience that we have the same
concerns even the same fears and the
same hopes for the future of our
continent and what I want to tell you
what this is the mass of how I want to
work on Commission level on European
level a Europe which is close to people
I hope each cares about the concrete
issues from the citizens a commission of
the people that is what I want to work
for and having this in mind I think
jean-claude Juncker the current
Commission president called and named
his commission the commission of the
last chance
Santee he's on be commissioned president
I think he did a good job I want to call
the next Commission not the commission
of the last chance I want to call it the
commission of a fresh start of a new era
of readiness openness for optimism for
showing to the world that they can
achieve is European so much together
thank you thank you my friend Weber
finally France moments thank you good
evening you know you have the future of
Europe in the palm of your hands next
week you will decide the fate of Europe
in the next five years there are those
who say that Europe and the its citizens
are best served by breaking down the
European Union I don't believe in that
now those who say to avoid breaking down
the European Union we have to maintain
it as it is I don't believe that either
I believe to safe and strengthen Europe
we need to fundamentally reform your
it's time big companies finally started
paying taxes it's time we introduced the
minimum wage in every member state it is
time we have equality in pay of men and
women it is time we put an end to
violence against women in Europe it is
time we enforce the rule of law in every
member state so that everybody about
abide by the rules it is time we put the
climate crisis and sustainability on the
very very top of the list of the next
commission that is my proposal to you
tonight Thank You France in my mind
since you - or for your introduction but
you know it surely waits to you in front
of your screen so let me join Anna
steena now online for all social media
posts Anna steena maybe there is already
some reaction some tweets for doing we
can instigate yes Emily welcome to the
social media hub as you see we are here
following all your comments and
questions with my team and yes the
conversation it has already started it
has been very lively questions have
actually been pouring in already before
the debate
and hashtag tell Europe it is already
trending in Belgium and in Germany
unless you can imagine there are some
topics that are already very popular
online any idea what they are well let
me tell you bricks it climate change
digital privacy and migration in fact
Seawatch have tweeted using hashtag tell
Europe that they rescued 65 people from
the Mediterranean today so clearly this
is a major issue so make your voice
heard keep your comments coming and
questions coming and use the hashtag
tell Europe let's get back to the main
stage and get started with the debate
[Music]
thank you very very much Ernestina for
this first glimpse into the social media
landscape and we are also starting on
migration this has been the topic most
mentioned by many Europeans when
surveyed about their concerns but Europe
has failed to find a common political
solution for the problem the ideas of
resettlement are met with opposition and
even for a few dozens of migrants
arriving on ships like the Seawatch or
on their carriers we see our governments
fighting who is going to take them so
our question to you is given the
fracture the tensions we see about
migrations would you as a commission
president drop the efforts to find a
common solution and it's not how do you
solve the problem the question goes to
mr. zahary please thank you first of all
I have to say that I would never repeat
the same mistake like the current
Commission by introducing mandatory
quota which unfortunately didn't work
and which unfortunately only deepened
the divide between eastern part and
western part of Europe I believe that we
should find another solutions we should
respect the sovereign right of
governments and Parliament's in Member
States to grant or not to grant asylum
to grant or not to grant temporary or
permanent settlement or even citizenship
what we have to do is however to fight
human trafficking and human smuggling
what we have to do is to outsource
reception centres to outside of the
European Union otherwise we won't be
able to fight trafficking and smuggling
we of course have to somehow conduct
readmission agreements with other
countries and that they will be willing
so we have to cooperate closely and
first of all we have to have stabilize
situation in Africa thank you thank you
mrs. our ideal match with paper what
would you do
the only chance is the European solution
no doubt about this and there are two
main pillars for us as EPP one pillar is
that the state controls who is arriving
in Europe and not
Smuggler's that we have to win back the
control on our border and that must be
clear that's why we asked for 10,000
from text officers immediately
established to control the borders the
second element is when Pope Francis is
in front of the lamp of the military and
seen Lampe Tulsa and is reminding us on
our humanitarian responsibility we have
to take over this responsibility we have
to care that means resettlement for
Syria that means a big martial plan for
Africa I want to establish a
commissioner only dealing with African
interests to make also from structure of
the Commission clear that we priorities
things and there are the two sides of
the metal strict border control and
humanitarian responsibility and my party
did it so Angela Merkel the Chancellor
of Germany Germany we showed that we
take over responsibility and Angela
Merkel to get together with jean-claude
Juncker showed also that we are ready to
have a turkey agreement where we win
back the control on our border so both
elements are crucial thank you very much
Manfred Weber mr. krei would you drop
the efforts let me recall that
immigration is first and foremost a
human drama and I'm actually the son of
an illegal immigrant
my parents arrived here without any
documents and more than 30 thousand
people have been killed in the
Mediterranean 50 people were killed just
yesterday in the Mediterranean when a
boat capsized and I think the European
Union has a great responsibility here
and all of the policies that have led to
destabilization need to be revised for
the European left
we believe that migration is an
opportunity I'm an example of that this
is an opportunity for a series of people
who don't have the opportunity back home
in their countries to flourish for us
we're not in we don't believe that it's
about the invasion of Europe we're
talking about 0.5% of the population and
these people can contribute to
rejuvenating Europe I am the son of a
migrant and I think the statement of mr.
Weber where he talked about a final
solution for immigration is scandalous
thank you
Wester girl what would you do with my
ones I having on ships exact queries for
example well I think the important thing
is to treat a sort of the long-term
stable solution with the same urgency as
saving life at sea because otherwise we
will never get to a solution because
migration is here to stay because of
climate change because of changes in
economic conditions but the most
important thing is that I see Europeans
having an open big heart for Refugees to
protect people in need of protection and
at the same time to expect us to find
ways to manage migration and to make it
legal because we cannot have people
coming and going without knowing and in
that of course we need exactly common
solutions we need a common Asylum system
and we need a common solidarity and we
can discuss how to make that happen but
we need to do that together because
otherwise we'd fail Thank You magnet
America so we heard a lot about what
about what we should do
France timmermans as acting first
vice-president of the Commission saw
what is difficult to do what could be
done better under your watch as
president of the European Commission I
think first of all every time a person
dies in the Mediterranean Europe loses a
bit of its soul so we're losing who we
are we're losing our values by not
solving this problem secondly once
people are on boats in the Mediterranean
you have to take care of these people
and you shouldn't put fines on fishermen
or other people in other boats who
rescue people at sea like the Italian
government is doing now that is
unacceptable thirdly you have to prevent
people from getting on those boats in
the first place and for that you really
need I agree with Manfred Weber a huge
plan for Africa you need to understand
that Europe's destiny is linked to
Africa's destiny but only with these
measures and better border protection
and agreements with third countries we
will not solve it we also need
solidarity in Europe solidarity is not
just for things you like it's also
sometimes for things you don't like and
if central Eastern European countries
continue to refuse solidarity sooner or
later borders will be
in Europe where they don't belong and
that would be to the detriment of every
citizen in Europe we need to prevent
that we need solidarity gives it clear
perspective thank you thank you thank
you France no man has a president's
European Commission what would you do we
stand clearly for a European solidarity
we need to fairly share the
responsibility that we need to face we
also need to support the communities
that are actually doing so much already
to welcome people and need many cities
many people many initiatives are helping
but really what is absolutely
unacceptable is what's happening right
now in the Mediterranean people are
drowning and we know where they are they
are calling the search and rescue center
no one is picking up the phone the
Italians are telling them to call the
Libyans in Libya no one is answering the
phone there's a civil war in Libya there
is no Coast Guard and we're even giving
to those militias which call themselves
Coast Guard's support this should not
happen we need to have a European
search-and-rescue effort because we
should not allow that any single person
dies in the Mediterranean thank you
thank you specular thanks for the first
one of francerz how second question is
on youth unemployment if you look into
the details you see there is a huge gap
between countries in the north and east
and those like Greece Portugal Italy or
even friends you stand on prime youth
unemployment in Greece for instance is
at 39% but what is the explanation for
that too much austerity like in Greece
or Portugal or maybe not enough reforms
like perhaps in France or in Italy a
question to the candidate how would you
try to bring the Moors and 3.3 million
young Europeans back into jobs mr.
cyrodiil so for us well first of all
let's be very clear that this is not the
European Commission which creates jobs
businesses create jobs and European
Commission can create
this friendly environment by good
legislation and by funding good programs
from its budget and some good programs
have been already developed we have for
instance digital Europe funded by I
think 10 billion of euros
we have also horizon Europe which is
supporting research and development with
another part of the European budget and
we have also invest you which combines
private and public resources for
improving infrastructure so what I
believe is that we need some tailor-made
solutions for each and every country
because our economies are very diverse
structures of our national economies are
different and if you look at Europe you
can see that in some countries is
actually unemployment very low in my own
country is less than 3% so tailor-made
solutions encouragement of new programs
and good legislation these are my
solutions thank you and Zara do we take
it to Manfred Weber
Germany also in this always insists on
austerity on the 3% criteria is this
also a cause for the youth unemployment
in the South we're seeing and are you
gonna change something about it well I
remind the Chairman's they touch the
Austrians to finish who doing quite well
at the moment economically that they
only can have a good future if it can
create jobs and growth especially for
the young generation in the south the
only can a lotta challenges together so
its responsibility and solidarity
together we have to bring these things
in one line and I want to describe one
element that was in protocol in Porto I
met with young students there and they
told me that France they were not first
of all asking about minimum wages
because that is one of the proposals
from the Socialists they were asking the
young generation the south is asking for
jobs for good paid jobs for good
salaries to establish their own families
and that's why we need a good economic
policy to create to create these jobs
and that is infrastructure that is
research that is openness for trade and
that is for all of us to practice a
strong single market to establish even a
stronger single market for the future so
socialists what is creating shops
thank you thank you Matt converges
remember you have to we better count to
challenge other candidates so Nico Kui
do you agree with Manfred Weber economy
a good economy policies a solution to
get unemployment down in Europe imagine
possible
no I don't think so because they're in
power now and they've been in power for
a long time but the policies are
completely not up to the job within the
euro more austerity labor law reforms
precarious work that's wages and
salaries which often are below the
minimum wage and at the same time
increasing the pensionable ages which
means that the older people are working
until 65 and young people are sitting at
home out of a job we have to put an end
to precarious work and get back to
proper labor contracts which have got
prospects not just 0s comp contracts
which don't give young people any kind
of future at a European military a
European minimum wage which is worth
getting up for in the morning that's
what young people want and this proper
labor contracts should be on offer to
young people across Europe thank you
[Applause]
just like the general business
environment we can do something about
but not really giving an answer to
millions of young Europeans who want a
job well I think we can do both because
European countries have come together to
make sure that in every country there is
an offer of education or training or a
specific job because with with no job
you just open the door to no future and
of course it's very good points that we
need a strong economy we need to invest
we need to make sure that businesses can
do business and grow and we see jobs are
being created in Europe I think more
than 12 million jobs over the last five
years but a lot of those jobs they don't
pay very well and we should agree that
we should promote an economy where you
can make a decent living when you have a
full-time job and that may be another
discussion than having a sort of fixed
minimum wage because we have different
systems and that I think is important to
respect that because we need to call on
the social partners to help us out
because the European Union as such can
do something but together with member
states then we can solve it thank you so
France tournaments you can answer the
vice president of European Commission
now as a future president of European
Commission well first of all I'm when
I'm in Portugal young people in Portugal
asked me when Antonio Costa came with
plans to create more social justice to
get more jobs to create more economic
growth and the European Commission said
go ahead montfort Weber said no punish
Portugal punish Portugal so that's the
question I got but coming back to the
question on the young people first of
all very concretely let's expand Erasmus
to every young person in Europe
regardless of whether they are in school
or in university or in high school
whether they have a job or not a job it
gives them an experience to learn from
other Member States
secondly make sure there is a minimum
wage that is on average 60% of median
wage that will protect young people
against these jobs where they get two or
three euros an hour thirdly
youth guarantee plan expand the youth
charity plan it's been very successful
in quite a number of member states we
should expand that and more than that
lower the voting age to 16 years so that
young people have biggest say in the
decisions we take it national European
level thank you I already thought they
agree on everything apparently but know
that we saw the first rebuttal card from
monthly Babar
so 30 seconds for you and then 30
seconds an answer from France diplomat
so we all share that solidarity is a key
issue for Europe but again
responsibility and on responsibility I
have to remind everyone that in the last
five years it was Commissioner Moscovici
socialist responsible for the
programming on the euro question it was
Thais diploma former colleague of France
timmermans as Minister from Netherlands
was chairing the echo fiends of the Euro
group which did the necessary decisions
on reforming and today it's a socialist
finance minister from Portugal who is
chairing this ECOFIN group the
responsible body the Euro group the
responsible body who is doing the
necessary steps so I think everybody
should take over responsibility the
Socialists had nothing to do with what I
said gab Moscow VC looked at the plans
and said they're okay
jean-claude juncker looked at the plans
of Portugal and said okay this can work
and the monthly labour said from the
European Parliament no we will not allow
this you should punish Portugal they
shouldn't do this and this is what
happened it worked
social justice is bigger in Portugal
jobs have increased enormously in
Portugal because they put an end to
austerity and that is what more
governments should be doing thank you
very much
guns to my mouth and
faster line on that is sky : please I
think there are stereo team measures
that have been taken in Europe have
really done a big damage it has done a
damage to people personally people were
deprived of their jobs I mean it's young
people very much but it's not just young
people but it also also really given a
blow to that European promise of that we
would be jointly creating prosperity so
I think it was a big mistake for every
sort of mission we shouldn't forget if a
young person is unemployed that will
mean that young person will have a lower
income in the future as well so tackling
youth unemployment is crucial and it's
an issue for the whole of the European
Union not just from single member states
or regions so we should make the youth
guarantee binding everywhere and it
needs to be fully financed and we need
to make sure that we have the right jobs
in the future investing in the greenie
common economy even the Commission has
said it will create hundreds of
thousands of jobs so why do we wait with
that why not start with making sure that
investments we do are exactly targeted
towards the social and ecological
transition of our economy since you
general generally I want to say you
something if I may
how would you would you agree that there
is a very diverse level of unemployment
that individual member countries you
have over ten percent in some countries
and we have less than three percent in
some other countries would you agree
that this is a very good evidence and
very good example that in fact national
governments and national parliaments are
better able to create tailor-made
solutions for their own labour market
than the European Commission can do with
me
that if we had applied the same
reasoning on structural funds for new
member states 15 years ago the Czech
Republic would not be as prosperous
today the unemployment in the Czech
Republic would not be as low as it is
today so without structural Fonz's what
happened they were how exactly exactly
and this was an expression of European
solidarity would you not agree with me
that it's also an expression of European
solidarity not just to say we have low
unemployment figures but we care
about the fact that in southern Europe
more than 30 percent of the young people
are unemployed and we will help solve
that oh thank thank you very much
Lance Timmerman and I hope you
understand why I encourage you to use
your rebuttal card so we are getting
kind of the debate now thank you all
Thank You sky cooler thank you all for
your first answers on migration and on
youth unemployment old fashioned here on
the stage but let's have a look at the
fancy social media stage yes it has been
great to see that thousands of you are
are already getting involved the hashtag
tell Europe has been mentioned more than
7,000 times and let's see how far that
goes by the end of the night I really
hope to see the Finns here too because
you know last night we didn't do that
well in their semi-finals of the
Eurovision Song Contest so make your
voice be heard tonight and all your
other Europeans of course - and speaking
of engagement many of you sent us your
reasons for going to vote at the
upcoming elections in a European
Parliament poll you told us that you are
voting to fight climate change change
Europe for the better to stop so-called
toxic nationalism and to tea keep
democracy going so how is the online
community responding to our first topics
let's have a let's have a look migration
it has definitely provoked a very heated
discussion this user from Belgium would
like to see EU citizens allowed to
support migrants with shelter and food
and I can also tell you that there is
huge interest in climate change many of
you have sent in all kinds of questions
on this subject from Germany we have a
direct question asking candidates what
they will do to fight climate change and
to prevent crisis we'd like to hear more
from the candidates so let's get back to
the debate
[Music]
thank you Anna snuff was a perfect
transition because we can move on on the
next topic environment and climate
change
they are your CCR thousands of Europeans
young Europeans out on the streets with
with a Sun bank with a Fridays for
future movements every other week we get
a new scientific we brought Eugene
politicians like you to act George to
act but still effective climate
protection could prove very expensive
jobs in the core or car industry will be
lost energy costs ordinary people more
money so our question to the candidate
is do you think we have to make
sacrifices in order to protect the
planets our planet what would you do
more or while what would you do less
please name name crew quit proposal
Mallory style well of course it's the
risk but I think we can make the most of
it by looking at it as an opportunity
because millions of jobs can be created
for instance building high-speed rails
in Europe to connect our cities to make
sure that people can get around out of
the planes bound to the trains that is
very specific that can work and second a
lot of things is now prepared we have
set targets we have the legislation to
reform our markets now we can go do a
lot of the technology we need we have it
already so we can invest European forms
and national funds and of course we can
research even more than we do today but
we don't need to wait for technology we
have so many things to do already and
the greatest thing is that while we do
something systemically each and every
one of us can take part by our not our
personal choices but we can never just
decentralize it - each and every citizen
because this is something that we'll
have to do together
thank you very much Michael a divest
tiger
Scarah I assume you take the climate
goals very serious but other greens also
ready to accept job losses to achieve we
take this issue very serious and I think
we all should because this is a serious
urgency we only have one single planet
and we need to protect it we cannot do
it compromise and say to the climate you
know just wait a bit we're still not
sure what to do no we can't do that but
the good thing is that we know what to
do the policy instruments the measures
that we need to take we know them we
have them on the table we just need to
do them and that has been a problem that
unfortunately other groups present here
have constantly voted against progress
in fighting that climate crisis and it
really is crisis especially if we
combine it with the loss of biodiversity
so this is really a hot and very
important issue that we have to address
what I would do this for example
stopping the climate harmful subsidies
that we're spending every year at the
European Union level there's billions of
euros that we should stop putting into
the wrong use and put it into good use
for example in climate friendly
technology which for example also
creates a lot of jobs all the new jobs
that would be would be created in the
climate friendly technology and economy
that would be here to stay right now
we're letting them go to China thank you
thank you
France timmermans other vice-president
of European Commission do you heard the
young European into the street do you
heard zero we thought of the scientific
yep it's what I hear everywhere I go
every day 10 times a day every day first
of all let me say Scott has said Scott
Keller has set some clear words about
this mr. kuai is one of the leading
leading politicians in the European
Parliament on climate change and on the
environment the three of us already have
quite good record in the last five years
in the European Parliament my offer to
them is let's work together in the next
five years so that we make sure the next
commission puts the climate crisis on
the top of its agenda and I'm sure we
will also convince many many people in
the Liberal family so that we create an
alliance going from C plus all the way
to my core to make sure we put this on
the
highest level of our agenda but
concretely why are we not taxing
kerosene we're taxing the the fuel in
the cars and then the trains but on the
airplanes unacceptable why are we not
introducing a co2 tax for all companies
in Europe a co2 tax which revenues we
can then bring back to the people so
that they can make their housing
sustainable for instance so why are we
not introducing these measures we can do
that we can do that if we agree with the
Member States and if we enforce this
also with the help of the European
Parliament thank you very much France
the moment and I think we saw the first
stage of coalition building here but I
assume we go to the opposition now Yan's
our deal what would you do more on
climate protection or perhaps less look
I came from that part of Europe
centuries in Europe which 30 years ago
was one of the most polluted parts not
of only of Europe of the world now we
over those 30 years we have reduced the
air pollution for hundreds of percents
so it is achievable but it has to be
done in a socially sustainable way and
gradually while introducing new
technologies and that's what I'm calling
for socially sustainable way and gradual
phasing right sign table so let's not
put unrealistic targets ahead of us
let's commit those commitments let's
fulfill those commitments we have signed
for instance the Paris climate agreement
I rather come to when it comes to the
Commission Commission could and should
change the way how for instance our
subsidies from a common agriculture
policy paid they should be more
environmentally oriented more subsidized
organic farming small farming and not
only production oriented and there is
one more actually a good program which
was already devised by the Commission
and I have to praise the Commission for
that it's called one hectare and this I
will explain later we're sorry for that
yes thanks
thanks Jillian Zara's they only cook
cooing if she don't well I'd like to
thank the young people who for the many
weeks now have been going out on the
streets because they get the impression
that they are not being listened to and
it's true they haven't been listened to
we hear lots of fine words from European
politicians but there haven't been any
concrete measures taken we are not
attacking the big polluters the
multinationals who were responsible for
more than 70% of pollution at the
international level
we're doing nothing there rather with
pushing this on to citizens taxing the
citizens as macron has done in France
that is totally unacceptable
there is an industrial tradition in
Europe
Galileo Airbus why can't we go back to
taking a public initiative to deal with
the climate crisis we can't simply say
there's no money we found three billion
to save the banks and mr. Timmerman tax
evasion is at about 800 billion and we
take it to matrick-verner would you be
more ambitious on climate protection
than the actual acting commission now 50
to achieve a European Union which is
carbon neutral that is our common goal
and that's why I cannot understand why
we create here to have divisions and we
have come an understanding about what to
do for the future the EPP is clearly
committed to this goal but on the way
how we achieve this there are
discussions necessary because I don't
accept that the losers of the
development will be the pensioners to
put people in our societies will be the
industrial workers of the car industry
we have a lot of concerns about that as
I can manage this transitional period
there are a lot of concerns on the table
rural areas again and that's why we have
to make it in a way that everybody can
respect it and when I refer to my EPP
party I tell you it was the Commission
areas Kennedy and if you be Commissioner
presented all the initiatives in the
fight against climate change how they
achieved
are together vcp be vice and I will
continue thank you my man you want to
challenge just very briefly I mean we
just an NGO went through the voting in
the European Parliament over the last
five years and they call the EPP
dinosaurs so there is a problem there
it's not my word it's what the NGO did
just looking at the voting but secondly
I'm sick and tired of the excuse it's
going to hurt pension it's going to hurt
socially weak people you know it's
really going to hurt if we do nothing if
we do nothing we'll be in a climate
crisis of incredible proportions if we
do nothing it's the poor people who will
suffer first they have no way to go
somewhere else to avoid this crisis we
need to act the longer we wait the more
expensive it is and the harder it is and
poor people Mareeba again from Philemon
great words but not concrete actions you
see we need concrete actions now and
that is necessary for achieving the goal
and I tell you the trade emission system
which we established into the European
Union we can expand this to the aviation
sector that would be an important step
or to look for the question how we can
now boost innovation I believe as an
engineer I'm an environmental engineer
by my profession I believe in innovation
not in punishment not in bands not in
regulatory framework I believe in
innovation and that's by establishing an
horizon which is investing in
technologies which are capable to solve
the problems that is what we have to do
okay time is up for that we have a lot
of further question on that because we
have two more rebuttal cards first
scapulae I think we have great
differences among the groups among the
parties on the climate issue because
some only talk about the climate and
others like we want to do something
about it very concretely so my very
concrete question to monthly but it's on
that if you're saying emission trading
is great then why did you vote
personally why did your group vote
against reforming the ETS and making it
actually workable right now we're giving
out so many free certificates that they
can go for free and even trade the
certificates among themselves the very
big companies why did you vote against
that why did the EPP vote against more
ambitious climate targets
this is not at all what real climate
action looks like before being it we
give it a massive favor just very
briefly ETS wheels emission trading
system for those of you who are not
familiar with that abbreviation monthly
vapor please exactly because my party is
the party who trying to bring things
together we can be ambitious and at the
top of the greens in a way to be very
strong on climate change and again I was
a meeting had a meeting with the trade
unions not with CPP voters - trade union
socialists who told me if you implement
the goals of the Greens then we have no
future of the for our chops and that is
why let us be sustainable sustainability
from the United Nations means ecological
ambition also economic stability and
also the question of sustainability in
the technological fields bring things
together and not split them up
you will answer again because magnet
Vassago I want to challenge you and this
is because you sort of insists that my
colleague Miguel is a EPP but he didn't
make amazing work because he's EPP he
did that because he's part of the
Commission my colleague Violeta she
didn't pave the way to decarbonize
transportation because she's liberal we
work together as a college and this is
not a party congregation because climate
change is so much bigger than any of us
that party affiliation plays a role and
second we have so many tools already why
not just put that introduce instead of
just waiting thank you
but margarita that was exactly my
starting point when I said let's not
create a division on this because of the
goal we are on the same side and frankly
speaking you know that in the liberal
group there are a lot of friends who
share the concerns about the speed of
implementation again 2050 we have to
have a carbon neutral industry and I'm
strongly committed to do so but not to
punish the poor to do with this
innovation which offers to get the next
steps and to be strong on this thank you
very much Matt with paper and there was
still one more challenge from Nico grey
of
- you sure - Vasa well I think it's
pretty unbearable to hear this kind of
discourse you shut the f--- launch and
liege blast furnace seven or eight years
ago the unionists came up with all kinds
of proposals to create special Steel's
that didn't need to be washed and that
would have actually promoted and pushed
production levels for recycling of these
materials imagine the number although
the quantity of detergents that we
wouldn't afford down the drains and
produced in Europe but instead with mr.
Tierney you preferred to plump with mr.
metal and allow these blast furnace to
be shut down and allowed steel to be
brought in from outside of Europe and
which will pollute the world twice as
much I want to comment in a way that we
have to understand that the Europeans
are ambitious but for the next
Commission presidents a main goal could
be also to convince the rest of the
world to follow because we cannot alone
rescue the climate we have to do it
together with the other friends and with
the other partners on global level and
that's why the European Commission the
European Union must be ambitious on the
global stage to work for a for a global
development for an engagement on global
level to fight together against climate
change that is what I want to do more so
no hope from where we'll start in Europe
for goodness sake answers and we go
further to the next topic next topic is
one that might come across slightly
technically but I think it's one that
annoys many people across the continent
because it's a symbol of unfairness and
injustice multinational corporations
like Apple Google or Nike are paying
only marginal taxes of often less than
5% where we as ordinary citizens have to
pay between 20 and 40 percent our
question to the candidates is which
countries in the European Union are in
European tax havens and how do you
change their behavior to make sure that
Amazon pays as much taxes as The
Bookseller next door we start with
Margaret Emma Sarah I have dealt with
this firsthand so you're very generous
when you say that some only pay 5%
because someone pays 0.05%
in some years as we saw it in the Apple
case so there is indeed work to do and
what we have seen is now member states
they change taxation in Ireland in the
Netherlands in Luxembourg in Belgium in
Malta in Cyprus because change is coming
and we have changed the legislation all
over but we need two things we need
digital taxation because a lot of these
companies they are escaping and most of
the companies they actually do pay their
taxes this is unfair and second we need
to put a floor under corporate taxation
as such because otherwise it will just
be a race to the bottom and we need
companies to contribute to societies
where they do a very good business and
the cases so many businesses do that
already and we need tax fairness very
briefly the countries you named are they
tax havens but for me it's axe Haven is
the place for everyone pays their taxes
[Applause]
mr. Sekulow are you as a optimistic as
McGregor change is coming I really hope
so because this is a real serious
scandal that we're having right now I
mean you mentioned how little or you
mentioned how little taxes are being
paid by the big company so the strongest
memory so to self society are running
away from their responsibility and that
is costing us so much taxpayers money in
money that we don't have to build
schools to repair hospitals to have a
good educational health care system so
absolutely it is key that we have tax
justice this is part of social justice
so we need to indeed have a tax for the
digital big companies that can easily
evade taxation and we need to have a
minimum tax rate for companies but what
we also need is transparency and this
net needs to go for every company and
there we have already tried to establish
rules for the transparency so that it's
clear how many employees does a company
have in one country or not because this
is get attention
unfortunately the Liberals as well as
the Conservatives and the further
conservatives have voted for exemptions
to this transparency but I think there
should be no exemption to transparency
transparency goes for everyone thank you
very much Scott Keller and next in line
trance timmermans your home country was
already mentioned is it the tech safe
well they've seen the writing on the
wall that this doesn't work anymore and
they're changing in it was about time
actually and I agree fully with Margita
when she says we need a corporate tax
minimum level in the whole of Europe I
would say let's put 18% as a minimum
level and then you have a fair playing
field and then countries can decide to
do more but they can no longer decide to
do less the thing is the economy has
changed so fundamentally we are in the
fourth Industrial Revolution we have
companies who have found ways not to pay
taxes at all Margot is right these big
companies don't pay taxes so we should
keep asking Alexa Amazon when are you
going to pay taxes thank you very much
and centuries
20 seconds I would like to ask you if
you propose 80 percent corporate tax how
do you get Ireland agreeing on that I
think you know they are see that this is
hurting their economy in the long run
anyway you know these big warehouses
with nobody's working it's not in the
interest of any economy and so I think
we can convince everyone to follow that
road it's also an element of European
solidarity I'm even sure we can convince
my own country in this thank you thank
you for amendments yes that ideal what
do you think about transparency - well
first of all I have to say that there
will be probably very fundamental
difference amongst us because I believe
that states have the right to tax
businesses and European Union is not a
state maybe some people wish European
Union to be a state and in that case I
understand that they are calling for
pan-european taxes I don't I believe
however that of course tax evasion
should be forbidden I believe that there
were good steps made however there is an
exchange of informations for every
company whose turnover is bigger than
750 million of euros whether it pays
regularly taxes here on there so we can
easily identify those who do not pay
taxes and they can be taxed on a
national level I don't think that they
should be taxed on a pan-european level
and by the way I have to say that
Commission Festa did a very good job on
that on the filing level playing field
and on trying to find a proper
competitive environment for European
businesses thank you very much yandere
do and Nico quay do you agree that it's
none of yours
Europe's business taxation or less but
it - not at all I think we've got to
recognize that in Europe we have got
whole areas where all the public
services have been done away with the
hospital's the schools public transport
frontline services have been taken away
and that they have to be in existence to
spend the tax money on even harmonizing
taxation our European level and getting
rid of the tax dumping which is which
Mars the landscape in Europe that's been
going on for years
those were plans but nothing has
materialized nothing's come of that so I
think we've attempt to go from fine
words to hard action on tax fraud 850
billion how many schools have mean how
much public services health care how
much could you get for 850 billion euros
and let's have the common decency to say
that there are whistleblowers they are
key in lambasted the what's happening
and they should be protected and not
attacked thank you very much I was a
proud European man the European
Commission decided to to act against
Ireland Margherita you and jean-claude
juncker to make clear that Apple has to
pay their fair contribution to our
European societies and that is what we
have to continue to use our economic
strengths a regulatory framework to make
clear that everybody has to pay and you
have to answer one question because we
share to fight against tax havens we
share that we need a digital taxation I
want to use the money of such a digital
state taxation for the transforming
process for those who are the losers of
the digitalization so we share the
common idea but the big question is how
to do it and that's why we have to
change in some special fields in
taxation from the unanimous vote to the
majority making decision process that is
that that it's a test let me say whether
we really believe in this approach of a
common European engagement generally
speaking I believe in text competition
but in special fields like the digital
taxation we need a common European role
I just learned soon as this stage of
visited by to all use your first Tribal
Council
you have still won in the last report or
capture challenge other candidates thank
you for you answer and buy one on
taxation they are certainly hot topics
we experienced that let's see now how is
it online yes we're back at the social
media hub and you've been very very busy
online using the hashtag tell Europe and
making your voice heard so I want to
thank you for that to give you a better
sense of what people are saying online I
would like to show you a word cloud so
climate and green they are definitely
the most popular keywords being typed in
and as you can see many of you are also
interesting interested in getting to
know the candidates themselves and also
knowing more about the Commission and
the elections which are taking place
from the 23rd to the 26th of May and
another very popular topic we have come
across is gender equality this person
would like to know how candidates are
going to tackle the gender pay gap and
with the rise of Euroskeptics
and populist movements in several
European countries some of you have also
expressed some general distrust towards
the European Union here is a tweet from
Germany that I think sums up what some
people some of you feel so they think
that EU is they don't people feel that
it's not well enough explained what the
EU does and what it is so keep sending
in your comments and questions with the
hashtag tell Europe and let's continue
the debate online and on the main stage
[Music]
thank you very much Anna Sina and we
turn to questions about our external
politics do you in a world dominated by
the US and by China more and more often
you finds itself in an arm twisting
situation with those powers be it on the
Iran nuclear deal P it on North stream
to be it on free trade time and again
u.s. president on a trump threatens to
impose new tariffs on European goods so
this is a very broad topic but we like
to get a feeling of your stance in these
questions and our question to you as
candidates for the European Commission
in order to strike a deal with Donald
Trump which will probably one of your
tasks as a commission president and to
avoid damage for the European economy
are you willing to open European markets
to American agricultural products
including genetically modified ones as
Trump apparently demands first answer
from sky Calabrese nope but I also think
we need to think a bit further and
really consider which role should the
European Union play in the world and I
think we would have an important role to
play and we need to consider which this
issue should be and we need to be united
in that my idea is that Europe should be
a force of peace and of human rights in
the world this is something where we can
really send out a strong signal and
we're already doing something right
we're the biggest donor for human rights
activists in the world but we're not
being coherent at the same time that
were the biggest human rights activist
donor
we're also as European Union member
states sending weapons to dictators
sometimes the same that oppressed them
so we need to be coherent we need to
stop those weapons exports into conflict
area which also sends people on the move
that then have to flee we should stop
being a haven for dictators that put
their money into European banks for
example we need to be coherent and we
need to care about human rights wherever
and whenever
[Applause]
gentleman how to be poor in front of
United States China well if we're united
we're stronger than that we are but if
we have leaders in Europe who are best
buddies with Vladimir Putin and go and
ask him for money who then go on an
audience to Donald Trump who wants to
weaken and break up the European Union
and you know how could we create unity
we have to understand what is at stake
for us as Europeans the first time in
living history that this is American
president who thinks it's in his
interest to have a weak and divided
Europe that's dangerous for us we can
divide it we will not be able to stand
up for our values in the world so we
need European unity and we need to
convince those political forces who
think that Putin is the best friend all
the way from Faraj to salvini to
Strucker all these people should
understand they are not acting in the
best interest of European citizens we
need to be united we need to stand firm
against Trump firm against Putin if we
do not do that they will dictate the
tone and the content of the music we
cannot allow that for the sake of our
citizens thank you very much fans
demands
Manfred Weber can we just say no one
everything to Trump he will pressure us
I think not at all because the Americans
are still our friends the American
people are our friends we have so much
common values in mind when we speak
about the freedom of press about the
independent judiciary about the gender
balance and and the democracy so there
is so much which we have in common
that's why I don't fight against the
American people but what is happening in
the White House is not our approach of
doing politics that's why we have to be
strict and clear I would offer to the
American president let's do a deal on
the industrial goods so let's do so on
trade but only if we practice
partnership if he wants to force us
Europe s to stand up and has to act
accordingly that's fine
strength and unity of Europe is
necessary and again we need the
mechanism discussed so today we have in
our external affairs the idea of
unanimous vote that's why Europe cannot
act Europe is not quick enough like this
oil in the Venezuelan case and that's
why we have to change towards a majority
making decision process only with such a
new mechanism
we can bring the whole strength of
Europe our value based alive for a
strong Europe and global stage so you
might say well okay what do you think
about the relations with United States
China sponsored well I think that free
trade agreements often wake weaken
Europe because we don't manage to get
partners to follow social and
environmental standards I think it's a
shame when we are the largest economy in
the world if you add together all of
Europe's countries we need to ensure
that European living standards are
respected free three trade agreements
need to be fair but they are being put
in the hands of private forms of justice
that member states fall victim to well
I'll give you an example
they only a question the Egyptian
minimum wage due to this private
arbitration that could simply overrule
States we need to be looking at the
rules in these kinds of treaties they
affect farmers industries the whole of
our populations in Europe that is how
that we will move forward here
this is would you talk about
agricultural goods well first of all I
have to say that trade for us for Europe
it's the major engine of economic growth
and I think that we should negotiate
with the United States because
transatlantic market is a huge
opportunity regardless who is at the
moment u.s. president but it's not the
only market there are also other markets
and I was very happy as a vice chair of
the international trade committee that
we conducted for instance the free trade
agreement with Japan which created the
largest free trade area in the world
covering about 30% of the global GDP and
I think it's a good news I think we
should continue that and I think we
should focus in times where protection
perfectionism is rising we should focus
on the goal to be a pie
of a free trade and we should try to
conduct more free trade agreements
particularly with Asian countries
because this is what economic future of
the world lies thank you very much James
I didn't meet Vista as a European
Commissioner for for competition you
were comforted with these other
countries is other power what do you
want to answer
well there's room for a much more
confident Europe as Nicolas sense this
is the biggest economic bloc in the
world with the biggest trading partner
with the preferred partner for 80
countries so a much more confident
Europe maybe also slightly more
hard-nosed
because if we give access to our markets
we should have access to other markets
as well and when we ask fair competition
within Europe we should also stand up
for our businesses if they are met with
unfair competition outside of Europe and
that we need to push much further than
what we have done so far and what we
have retired is basically you want me to
stop talking I read your body language
like that correctly go on thank you very
much
no the point is to say that we have
retired sort of the old concept of free
trade and instead said we need to trade
in a value-based way because we have
interest when it comes to how
agriculture is done how animals are
treated how human rights play a role and
this is why the trade agreements with
Japan with Canada are such good news
because this is the way you can make
trade a positive input and that creates
millions of jobs thanks Margaret America
there was another rebuttal from Nico
grey don't worry don't know who you want
challenged so on the shooting Murmansk I
I'd like to challenge mr. Timmons
because mr. timmermans vice-president of
the European Commission and I know that
in his political family at least in
Wallonia
there was a lot of pushback against the
setter treaty with Paul man yet as the
chairman for Wallonia we still don't
understand how it can be that if you
have a number of different visions for
the future through this treaty you can
accept that it is negotiated beyond the
states themselves and in some kind of
extrajudicial European forum are we not
sufficiently Democratic and strong for
us to debate this with the European
citizens so that democracy can really
take its place for good so cafe well I
can tell you straight away that what
Paul Meunier said and what you did
together really influenced very heavily
the nature of the treaty that really
made a difference you talked about
arbitration but actually it's much more
public now than it was and that's even
been confirmed by the Court of Justice
in Luxembourg so your actions and what
Portman yet did really helped us push
ahead in that direction which was much
more public but we haven't reached the
end of the road yet we've got a lot more
to do but already the trade treaties are
not just things that are decided on by
experts but they're part of the public
debate effort vivir if you want to use
your or lest we don't get too much who
you do you want to challenge the last
thing yeah I want to reflect on the
trade issue because today there is six
million shops in today's European Union
depend on trade we are trading continent
the whole economic strengths is based on
trade and that's why I cannot understand
why the Left parties the Greens the left
curve party in the group and also the
Socialists are not stable on the
question yes say yes to use trade as an
tool for making the world a better place
I would include in all the trade
agreements for the future a paragraph to
abolish child play child labor for
example on global level let's use the
trade issue for making the world a
better place and left you cannot count
on this on the klephts on this ration of
trade issues
[Applause]
is the divorce said in school middle
what well again that's fine words but in
practice social environmental standards
are going all the way down because of
those free trade agreements we haven't
got the machinery we have got agencies
at least that which can stand up to the
reduction of living conditions for
Europeans because what you always say is
that discourse that doesn't allow
Europeans to keep to maintain their
standard of living there is a domestic
consumption in Europe which is
substantial we are a big market and
millions of people who are working for
this internal economy and with your
international treaties the free trade
agreements they killed off that vitality
right in the heart of Europe because I
have been rebutted as well so I guess
I'm getting 30 seconds on that as well I
do think that trade can play an
important role but we have to see it as
an instrument to get to a goal and not
as a goal in itself as it's currently
being always treated the more trade
agreements we have the merrier but we
need to watch out what they do and for
example if we just liberalize all
services then this is also not good for
the European economy if we just extract
raw materials from other countries this
is really not good for achieving a
global and multilateral system of
development so we really need to be
careful what trade is done how and for
what a
a little Jana who do you want to
challenge this topic I have a question
for mr. Ferber because to my great
surprise he said that he would support a
qualified majority vote for a foreign
policy and I still believe that foreign
policy is something which is driven by
national interest and by a very concept
of state sovereignty and we see for
instance that in Libya Italy is
supporting general hafta while France is
supporting its vice-versa
the one country is supporting that
warlord while other country is
supporting the legitimate government in
Tripoli so how you can put this together
and how you can push one country by
majority vote to take completely
different stance I don't believe that it
could work and it would only deepen the
divide amongst European countries the
question is not how to manage it the
pre-crash the first version is is it
necessary and sorry when we see exactly
what is happening in Libya when we see
for example if this development in
Venezuela it took four weeks of time to
manage a common European position
against the communist regime of Maduro
four weeks of time due to some
individuals especially from Greece and
Italy and there is not the Europe I
dream about I dream of a Europe which
stands up for our values for Tremec
Rossi for rule of law for the pride
freedom which is the title of Europe the
freedom of our continent and that is
only possible if we come to majority
making this issue process let's make you
look strong in these versions Wi-Fi
sources thanks manfried river and
another rebuttal card for Margot a vest
a girl it's just a body challenging I
would just like to discuss trade with
star because I think there is also a
climate change dimension here for
instance we have a Slovenian company who
are very famous in developing electrical
planes we have great European companies
who develop pumps
wind turbines we have way of organizing
how to transform waste to resources and
all of those solutions are exportable
and you cannot export if you cannot
trace and you
trade as an instrument also when it
comes to bringing the world together
when it comes to using the best possible
solutions that we know already I agree
and yes we don't want to stop trade but
indeed it needs to take care for example
of the climate dimension in the current
trade agreements that is not in anywhere
we don't take into account for example
all the co2 emissions that we're
creating the Paris agreement is not
mentioned in any of the trade agreements
even human rights are totally just a
nice addition decoration but they are
not sanctionable so we need to put the
Paris agreement our climate targets that
we have all agreed and into the trade
agreements and that we have tried to do
we haven't so far gotten a majority in
the European Parliament was but we're
struggling for that because indeed it
the Paris agreements the climate goals
need to be everywhere also in the trade
agreement I think you all use your
liberal can only France even once you
have a last paper to cut so we are
waiting for for it thank you for you all
for your answers so our final topic is
the increasing feeling of many people
that the European Union doesn't function
anymore
the British but to leave the Union in
Hungary Viktor Orban wins election with
the stallion stop versus in Italy metals
have any clearly well right same waves
and you can't values out under sweet
share with you all of flawed procedures
against Poland Hungary with more to come
and turnout for the election has
steadily declined over the decades so
our question to the candidate is how do
you explain the rise of your Sept ISM
and what is your share of responsibility
specular and what you say that the
problem is bigger the name of the
problem is bigger it's nationalism it's
dividing the European Union there's
forces that want to destroy the European
Union and that also don't recognize the
human rights of other human beings that
is the problem that we face in Europe
and there's a lot of things that of
course we need to do about that can do
about and I think one very
important one is not to give them too
much space because it's not a law of
nature that they have to become bigger
and bigger and they're not if we look
around in different European countries
we all as Europeans take part in the
decision of how much space we give those
nationalist forces in the Europeans and
also as European parties we need to take
a decision are we collaborating with
those extremist forces
unfortunately the EPP we have that
situation in Austria where you have been
partnering with the effort we have the
whole or one issue that hasn't been
solved yet so I think it's really it's a
problem of whether whether we should
take distance whether we say we stand
strongly on the basis of European values
and human rights or we don't do it
[Applause]
Simmons what is your share of
responsibility it'd be it politics be it
communications of the actual acting
European communities let's be very clear
people who used to vote for my party and
many parties here are now voting for
nationalist parties sometimes even
extremist parties that's our fault
apparently we did not convince them to
stay with us apparently they believe in
these propositions they're now being
disappointed look at what the divisive
nosov brexit has done to United Kingdom
today United Kingdom
looks like Game of Thrones on steroids
and that's because of this divisive
politics tomorrow's headline that's
there because of this divisive politics
so we have a collective responsibility
to offer propositions to our citizens
that will make them come back to the
European project will make them come
back to parties all the parties around
the table here who have constructive
propositions for the future this is the
only way forward and yes we are to blame
but we do have solutions and we talked
about these solutions tonight everybody
has this idea about this but we come
together on this idea of creating
European unity to solve the problems
that are facing us in the future Thanks
okay I don't want to say Ethiopian
existed
well the European Union existed but it's
being dismantled there is a risk that it
could be dismantled because we have seen
austerity policies of an unheard-of
violence used against southern European
countries that is why we shouldn't be
surprised to see people turning to
radical alternatives you should see what
the fascists are doing now within Italy
Hungary and elsewhere but we need to
make a choice either you choose the
markets and you're constantly submissive
to the law of the market or you take a
choice to support people the people who
live in Europe they are the ones that we
need to be addressing and looking after
but what have we been doing we've been
cutting their pensions increasing the
retirement age reducing the public
services giving them a feeling of
malaise of it is such that people think
that by withdrawing into their
nation-states they can be better
protected the responsibility is in your
hands you are the ones who pursued these
policies there are two left rebuttal
cards are with Skye Keller and Arsenal
nuts if I'm not mistaken but now it's
mantra paper soon my party the EPP the
Christian Democrats on this continent
are among the founding parties of
today's European Union and we see that
nationalism and echo is miss back of
this continent and what we have to do
over the 26 over of my for this year's
elections you have to find against Zeus
who wants to destroy our Europe you have
to defend our Europe no doubt about this
there are two elements important one
element is if you want to answer we have
to make Europe democratic in the brexit
case the main message of the proxy tears
was I want to have my sovereignity back
people feel not that Europe is my Europe
and I want to change this this chamber
the European Parliament is a place that
the future of Europe must be decided we
need a democratic Europe for the future
the second point I want to mention we
need a mechanism to defend our values
they are challenged in the in the whole
European
and that's why unbinding independent
rule of law mechanism for the future we
can also use the funds the money of
Europe to sanction soos who are not
ready to respect our fundamental
principles that is what I fight for as a
leader of reform is conservatives do you
want to defend Europe well I think that
the main problem is that people ordinary
people in European countries that do not
care about everyday politics somehow
tired from endless European integration
they feel that European units
interfering into their everyday lives
that it is threatening their traditional
ways of life their their social customs
and things like that so yes I am very in
favor in favor of European integration
and European Union as well but as I said
at the beginning I want Europe that is
doing less but better slimmer scale back
flexible decentralized I don't think
that more Europe and more Europe and
more Europe is the universal response
for each and every problem like
unfortunately EPP and socialists that
were running the European business for
the last 25 years and I don't believe
that I will be able to come with some
genuine change thank you yes I did
France moments I think mrs. are ideal
knows extremely well that I have had a
difference of opinion with the Polish
government whose party as part of his
group over the last three years and
people were saying oh don't do this it
would lead to Pollock's that people will
be disenchanted with you how does mr.
Cyril then explain that after three
years of very very tough conflicts with
this government the support for the
European Union in Poland is higher than
three years ago the Polish people attach
more importance to Europe than ever
before they want to be part of this
community of values give them bands or
withhold that from them thank you
gentlemen
[Applause]
[Music]
from the polish people but I give you
another example from my own country
90% of Czech citizens of course want to
stay in the European Union so that means
that they somehow like the idea of
European integration while 75% of my
citizens do not want to adopt the euro
so there is a clear example that people
somehow like the European Union but do
not like everything which comes from the
European Union and we have to find the
right balance between the European level
and the national level which are very
much in favour of European level
thank you very much and to
Margaritaville saga what makes people
turn away from the EU and do you see any
self-criticism I think there are many
reasons and if you want to change things
you need to change yourself first in the
way we talk we talk as very often as if
we were keeping a secret with all the
abbreviations we use last year we got
digital citizen's right that we called
GDP are how can you expect anyone to
appreciate that we need to speak in a
different way we need to take off the
labels when people come to say this is
the problem and discuss it for real but
then of course we also have to apply to
ourselves to tell the truth and what is
now done to fight all the fake news and
all the junk news that we see out there
that is part of the solution to give
people real food for thought and invite
them back to real discussion about how
we unite our national democracies and
our European democracy to make it work
in everyday life thank you very much
Margaret Avesta go we are behind our
schedule so very quickly to anissina
what's going on in the social media
world well we have had thousands of
people engaging with us 5,000 people
watching on YouTube 28,000 on Facebook
7,000 on Twitter and in fact we have
been trending so far on Twitter in
Belgium Denmark Germany Ireland France
and Finland rivers or mosquitoes
and well many of you have submitted
questions on specific topics a number of
you have also asked about broader issues
so for example from Italy we have a
question from a trip and European
citizen who asks why should I feel
represented by one of your national
parties so back to the main stage the
[Music]
candidates know how one final
opportunity to ask for your support so
the six of you stage would like to lead
you up for the next job three years so
one minute to close France Timmerman's
I sorry I have just 40 seconds because
we are scheduled starting with an
salamat
you have heard us today you've heard all
the differences I hope it helps you make
up your mind what you vote next week but
there's one thing I want to ask you
whatever you choose never become
indifferent choose let your voice be
heard if you don't vote somebody else
will take your voice it's like giving
your money to somebody else to decide
about your future vote in the European
elections let your heart speak vote for
the person or the party you believe will
fix Europe's problems best but vote
never let yourself become indifferent
[Applause]
if I would have the chance to ask my
grandfather the grandfather's generation
what do you think about today's Europe I
think they would answer the best Europe
be ever be ever saw and for the 26th of
May for these European elections is
first of all to defend it against the
echo s against the Nationalists were
back in Europe and I want to open the
new chapter I want to create optimism I
want to create future perspective for
this European Union for this great idea
of a united Europe and I say it again I
want to make it in a democratic way
where you have to say that you decide
about the composition of this chamber of
the European Parliament and V you give
her the advice what are the top subjects
but they have to deal with in the next
upcoming five years a democratic Europe
and a strong Europe two things first
it's important to show that we do change
and the most visible way to do it to
have a gender balance Commission same
net men the same number of men as the
number of women that reflects our
societies and second the challenges we
have been discussing today they're
difficult we need each other to do it
but it take courage to overcome
ourselves and our differences to find
common solutions the power to change
comes from you voting is power go vote
in this election and inspire people
around you to go vote otherwise other
people well you sit thank you
I would say that probably no one here at
this stage is happy with the state of
play of the European Union but each of
us has a different recipe what to do
with that my country joined the European
Union 15 years ago I'm coming from
rather different part of Europe maybe
with a different life experience and
maybe with different paradigm of
European integration and I have a
feeling that sometimes this is not
widely understood in other parts of
Europe that we are more sensitive to
questions like national sovereignty or
national identity so in order to work
together to live together to cooperate
together we have to find a way how to
sort it out and we have to find the
right balance between European level and
national level as I said at the
beginning thank you scattered all over
Europe young people are taking to the
streets because they fear for their
future and they turn that fear and the
anger at the politicians not doing
anything they turned that fear and
that's anger into action and we need to
do the same
we need to act because there is hope for
a better future and yes it can be done
but it does need change and it does need
courage and it does need a strong force
in the European Parliament that will
fight for climate protection for social
Europe and for democracy not just in
words but also in action and that is our
offer as grains to all Europeans
norther law well we've just seen that
European leaders they talk a lot but
they don't get to the heart of the
problems they're not dealing with
climate change global warming
precariousness they're not dealing with
tax evasion we want a Europe that
actually takes these problems and deals
with them
by the horns in Spain we want people to
vote for Europe for feminism in Italy
people are voting we don't want them to
vote for fascism we want all European
citizens to be able to vote for social
states that actually give them a decent
life and we want Europe to completely
change course we're asking them for a
vote for the European left which is the
only party that can really change
direction that brings us to the end of
our debate I hope you spotted somebody
whom you think would make a good
president of the next European
Commission but anyhow please join us all
in showing your appreciation for all the
six candidates
[Applause]
[Music]
Thanks
the conversation continues on I noticed
you know what's happenin lines well it
was very lively you send us so many
first that we couldn't get to all of
them but we did know that some of you
asked for more coverage of on the
European elections and we also know
there that we from a journalist from
France and fro that sums up what
tonight's debate has been all about a
discussion that is respectful and
meaningful about honesty Nam and to all
of you here in the parliament and of
course at home don't forget to take your
chance to vote from May 23rd to May 26
wherever depending on wherever you live
debate team for you every week good
night good night give a yachtie when
sorry
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]